.
- Anaïs Pronovost Morgan
gère l'organisme
Dignité mensuelle.
Leur mission : s'attaquerttaquer
à la précarité et l'éducation
menstruelle.
ANAÏS PRONOVOST-MORGAN,
Dignité mensuelle
- La précarité menstruelle c'est
un problème double. Ce n'est pas
juste un enjeu d'avoir
les produits disponibles et
accessibles. Mais aussi c'est
d'offir une éducation
menstruelle qui est souvent
manquante qui contribue
à la honte menstruelle."
- Elle croit que si tout
le monde comprenait les défis
auxquels font face certaines
femmes, elles seraient moins
stigmatisées.
En Espagne, on veut s'attaquer
à ce problème.
Le gouvernement vient de déposer
un avant projet de loi
qui comprend un congé de maladie
payé pour les douleurs
menstruelles invalidantes.
Anaïs la trouve excellente,
surtout pour assurer l'équité
entre les personnes qui
menstruent et les autres.
Mais croit que l'instauration
de ce genre de mesures doit
venir avec un suivi rigoureux.
- Ce qui est important avec
ces mesures-là c'est qu'on
les instaure et qu'on étudie
ses impacts pour qu'on puisse
ajuster le tirs selon les
problèmes qui en ressortent."
- Selon la docteur
Diane Francoeur, c'est aussi
une excellent nouvelle
car beaucoup de femmes
sont touchées.
- On peut aller jusquà 20 %
de la population qui sont
vraiment très, très incapacité,
clair qu'on ne peut pas
travailler quand on souffre
comme ça. Et c'est clair qu'on
ne devrait pas travailler
non plusnon plusnon plusnon plut
aussi souffrant.
- Des mesures similaires
existent dans plusieurs pays
d'Asie, apon, la Corée
du Sud et l'Indonésie.
Mais attention disent certains,
ces mesures peuvent discriminer
les femmes à l'e
ou au cours de leur carrière.
Ici Elisa Serret
Radio-Canada, Mo